oui c'est le jour de noël mais hier je
sais pas pourquoi dans la vidéo j'ai dit
qu'il y aurait une grosse annonce
aujourd'hui enfin pas une annonce mais
quelque chose d'un peu beauf
c'est le cas évidemment bonjour et
bienvenue pour la dernière vidéo du mois
de décembre et la dernière vidéo du
calendrier de l'avent ce que ce soir
c'est noël c'est les cadeaux c'est
l'amour c'est la famille c'est ce que tu
veux enfin ne fait pas l'amour à ta
famille d'ailleurs ça n'aurait aucun
sens mais par contre me suis demandé
comment j'allais finir cette vidéo je
vais vous le dire
quant à cette série de vidéos je vais
vous le dire c'est la dernière de
décembre là il y en aura plus je prends
quelques jours de repos et l'année
prochaine sur la chaîne
il va encore se passer d'autres choses
je sais on dit tout ça tout les youtube
heures on dit ça mais je crois que j'ai
vraiment besoin de ces quelques jours de
recul sur youtube pour revoir un petit
peu ce que j'ai envie de faire comment
j'ai envie de faire je me suis un peu
laissé prendre par le rythme avec tous
les projets que j'avais cette année tout
ça c'était vraiment cool mais j'ai envie
de retrouver encore plus de plaisir et
passion sur la chaîne
donc je ne sais pas quelle forme ça va
prendre ça va pas changer grand chose
pour vous en termes des articles vidéos
et tout ça mais moi ça me faire du bien
en fait quelques jours à réfléchir à ce
que je fais sur youtube
là pour terminer cette vidéo durant
durant presque un mois durant 24 jours
vous est présenté tout ce qui fait
partie de mon univers dense que je peux
qui fait comme jeu comme livres etc
je pense je pressens y en a qui vont
penser que ce déplacement de produits on
n'avait pas un seul sur la chaîne sur
ces 24 vidéo voilà je le dis je le
répète rien à jouer et je vous le dis
pas souvent parce que j'en fais très peu
c'est aussi simple que ça et donc ces
idées là aussi c'était peut-être des
idées de cadeaux pour vous se réfère à
vos proches soit recevoir et je suis
persuadé qu'il y en a qui ont demandé
des trucs que j'ai présentée comme
cadeau à noël
donc quel est le propos de cette vidéo
c'est que je vais vous donner
l'opportunité de gagner plein de choses
parmi celles que j'ai présentée alors
pas les miens qu'est ce que je vais pas
vous offrir les trucs d'occasion et puis
qui n'appartiennent pas envie des
données par contre je vais vous les
racheter moi même que mes petits deniers
pour vous les offrir je vais vous offrir
des choses qui avait dans ce calendrier
de l'avent 10 objets livres jeux et
c'est vous qui allez choisir quoi est
l'intérêt de faire ça c'est à dire que
noël va passer avant le tirage au sort
une fois que le tirage au sort sera
passée vous allez pouvoir aussi composer
en fait parmi tout ce que vous avez vu
sur la chaîne sur tout ce que vous
voulez en excluant les choses que vous
avez déjà ça vous évitera de voir des
doublons c'est un peu l'idée de ce
concours est la seule chose qu'il
n'entre pas en jeu d'un concours c'est
le cosmo puisque dans la vidéo 17 vous a
présenté ce petit robot qui était déjà
gagnée et je fais le tirage au sort
après demain le 26 c'est la vidéo 17
vous l'avez en lien juste ici là je vous
la met par là haut
donc ce sera à choisir parmi toutes les
options est ce que c'est bien clair dans
l'idée ce concours si vous le gagnez
vous créez un panier virtuel et vous me
dites dedans fabien tu mais çà çà çà çà
çà çà çà dit chose ni plus ni moins et
je vous achète ça et je vous envoie par
la poste
je vais mettre un tout en place dès
aujourd'hui vous allez donc le trouver
sur twitter ça me paraît évident et pour
participer à ça il faut me dire dans le
tweet le jeu qui vous ferait le plus
plaisir retweeter ce tweet et suivre mon
twitter je fais le tirage au sort le 3
janvier et si on passe d'ici le 3
janvier la barre des 10000 rt du tweet
jeffrey gagné deux personnes dont 42
personnes qui pensent faire un petit
panier comme ça avec un doublé j'espère
que cette idée des canaux vous plaira
c'est mon côté père noël j'espère que
vous avez été sages cette année un peu
de toi like et des pêcheurs ou le thé
strong ciao les prochaines pas mal je
vous kiffe
merci pour cet animal
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]